>> PROMISE TO THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC WHAT YOU COULD ACHIEVE IN
YOUR FIRST YEAR OF OFFICE.
DO YOU NEED TO BE MORE REALISTIC
AND SCALE DOWN THESE PRIORITIES.
>> WHY ARE YOU TRY SO HARD IN
YOUR FIRST YEAR TO PULL THE
COUNTRY SO FAR TO THE LEFT?
>> Carley: WHITE HOUSE REPORTERS
GETTING THEIR FIRST CHANCE IN
MONTHS TO QUESTION PRESIDENT
BIDEN ON THE EVE OF HIS FIRST
YEAR IN OFFICE.
>> Todd: FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
JOE CONCHA JOINS US NOW.
JOE.
THAT'S THE QUESTION, DID THEY
DELIVER?
>> I THINK THERE WERE SOME
POINTED QUESTIONS, TODD, CARLEY.
I FOUND THE QUESTIONS OVERALL TO
BE A BIT DISAPPOINTING.
LOTS OF MISSED OPPORTUNITIES.
NOT ONE QUESTION DURING THAT
TWO-HOUR PRESS CONFERENCE
YESTERDAY ABOUT VIOLENT CRIME
SKYROCKETING ACROSS AMERICA.
WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT IT BEFORE.
16 CITIES SETTING HOMICIDE
RECORDS IN 2021.  NOT JUST IN
CITIES.
IT'S SPILLING OVER INTO SUBURBS,
PLAY THE CLIPS OF SENSELESS
MURDERS GOING ON.
MANY VIOLENT CRIMINALS RELEASED
ON BAIL ONLY TO GO OUT TO COMMIT
MORE CRIMES LIKE WE SAW
WAUKESHA, WISCONSIN WHERE
GRANDMOTHERS AND CHILDREN WERE
RUN OVER.
SO, I THOUGHT THAT WAS A BIG
MISSED OPPORTUNITY.
CRIME IS SOMETHING THAT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE REALLY FEEL AND
I GET THAT RUSSIA IS A VERY BIG
DEAL.
BUT A LITTLE BIT TOO MUCH RUSSIA
FOR MY TASTE.
AND NOT ENOUGH ON DOMESTIC
ISSUES LIKE CRIME, WHICH WILL BE
A TOP TWO ISSUE IN THE 2022
MIDTERMS.
NOT ONE QUESTION ALSO AND WE
TALKED ABOUT THIS YESTERDAY
ABOUT THE FENTANYL CRISIS THAT
IS THE LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH
FOR THOSE IN THIS COUNTRY
BETWEEN 18 AND 49.
NOT ONE QUESTION OF WHY THE
PRESIDENT REFUSES TO VISIT OR
ADDRESS THE BORDER CRISIS THAT
IS A CATASTROPHE.
SO, AS WE HEAD INTO 2022, I
GUESS WE ARE IN IT NOW OR GO
MORE INTO 2022, THE CRITICISM IS
POLITE OF MR. BIDEN COMPARED TO
HIS PREDECESSOR THERE WERE SOME
SHARP EDGES I SAW ON CNN
YESTERDAY FOR EXAMPLE WHEN DAN
JONES FORMERLY OF THE
OBAMA-BIDEN ADMINISTRATION ON
CNN LAST NIGHT CALLED THE PRESS
CONFERENCE FOGGY, MEANDERING AND
COMPARED HIM TO RONALD REAGAN AT
THE END OF HIS PRESIDENCY.
WE KNOW THAT REAGAN WAS
DIAGNOSED NOT TOO LONG AFTER
WITH ALZHEIMER'S.
SOME CRITICISM.
CERTAINLY NOT THE VITRIOL LIKE
WE SAW WITH DONALD TRUMP.
BUT, AT THE SAME TIME, AGAIN
THAT PRESS CONFERENCE YESTERDAY,
I LIKED SOME OF THE QUESTIONS
FOR TWO HOURS BOY WE COULD HAVE
COVERED A LOT MORE GROUND.
>> Carley: NO QUESTIONS ON
EDUCATION EITHER, JOE.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Carley: VIRGINIA ELECTION AS
WELL.
I THOUGHT THAT ONE OF THE MOST
UNIQUE MOMENTS OF THE PRESS
CONFERENCE WAS WHEN PRESIDENT
BIDEN GOT PAD AS A REPORTER FOR
ASKING ABOUT HIS GEORGIA SPEECH
ON VOTING RIGHTS.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> YOU DISPUTE THE
CHARACTERIZATION THAT YOU CALLED
FOLKS WHO WOULD OPPOSE THOSE
VOTING BILLS AS BEING BULL
CONNER OR GORGE WALLACE BUT YOU
SAID THEY WOULD BE IN THE SAME
CAMP.
>> NO, I DIDN'T SAY THAT LOOK
WHAT I SAID GO.
BACK AND READ WHAT I SAID!
AND TELL ME.
>> Carley: SO I AM GOING TO READ
WHAT HE SAID.
DO YOU WANT TO BE ON THE SIDE OF
DR. KING OR GEORGE WALLACE?
JOHN LEWIS OR BULL CONNER?
SO WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE
PRESIDENT DENYING THIS -- WHAT
HE SAID INSTEAD OF OWNING UP TO
IT?
>> I THOUGHT THE REPORTER IN
THAT SITUATION COULD HAVE HAD
THAT QUOTE READY.
RIGHT?
HE PARAPHRASED WHAT THE
PRESIDENT SAID AND IF HE WAS
READY WITH OKAY, SIR, LET ME
READ BACK MY WORDS TO YOU JUST
AS YOU JUST DID, CARLEY, AND FOR
THE PRESIDENT TO REACT SO
ANGRILY REGARDLESS, THAT'S NOT
MR. UNITY WE ARE SEEING UP THERE
ANYMORE.
THAT'S GET OFF MY LAWN, JOE
BIDEN.
THAT DIDN'T PLAY WELL AT ALL IN
THAT SITUATION.
OVER ALL, I THOUGHT THE PRESS
CONFERENCE WAS A NET NEGATIVE
FOR THIS PRESIDENT.
I DON'T SEE A VISION FOR 2022.
HE IS GOING TO CONTINUE DOING
THE SAME THINGS.
THE SAME MESSAGING, AND THAT DID
NOT WORK IN 2021 WHEN YOUR
APPROVAL RATING IN QUINNIPIAC IS
ONLY 33%.
ONE OUT OF THREE AMERICANS
SUPPORTING THIS PRESIDENT RIGHT
NOW.
>>
>> Todd: ARE WE GOING TO SEE ANY
OF THESE PRESS CONFERENCES ANY
TIME SOON, JOE?
>> NO.
THIS ONE TOOK 300 DAYS BETWEEN
FORMAL PRESS CONFERENCES, THAT'S
ENOUGH TO DELIVER A BABY TO FULL
TERM, RIGHT, PLUS A MONTH TO
TAKE AFTERWARDS TO ENJOY THE
MOMENT, SO, YEAH, YOU WILL NOT
SEE ONE, I THINK, AT LEAST UNTIL
THE SUMMER.
NOT IN THIS SORT OF SETTING.
NOT FOR THAT PERIOD OF TIME.
BUT, CARLEY, I HEARD BEFORE YOU
ARE NOT A GOOD DRIVER.
YOU FROM JERSEY, HOW COULD YOU
NOT BE GOOD DRIVER FOR
SELF-SURVIVAL.
>> Carley: QUESTION OWN